die nasa hat einen wirklich krassen plan
schon im herbst 2022 soll ein asteroid
mit einem gezielten schlag aus seiner
bahn geworfen werden dort alles dazu
jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
die aktuelle situation ist folgende wenn
wir mit dem teleskop objekte am himmel
ausmachen würden die sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befinden
hätten wir kaum eine chance dieses
tödliche schicksal noch abzuwenden
konkrete abwehrmaßnahmen sind bisher
nämlich noch mangelware doch genau das
soll sich jetzt ändern da steht für
double es wieder rechten test und die
nasa will mit diesem manöver schon im
oktober 2022 ein absolut spektakuläres
und neuartiges aus soliden abwehr
verfahren testen das ziel wird der erste
doppel hast du mit 65 80 3 sein er wurde
1996 entdeckt und wenig später fiel dann
auch auf dass es sich bei dem objekt um
einen doppel körper handel deswegen sein
name die dumonts die griechische
bezeichnung für zwilling der größere
brocken von beiden hat einen durchmesser
von 800 metern der kleinere einen
durchmesser von etwa 150 metern
letzterer wird manchmal auch als diddy
moon bezeichnet er umkreist den größeren
die die moz körper in einer entfernung
von 1,1 kilometern und braucht für eine
umrundung rund 11,9 stunden und um das
direkt einmal klarzustellen das
zielobjekt ist aktuell keine bedrohung
für unsere erde
das nasa manöver dient lediglich dazu
uns für den ernstfall vorzubereiten die
flugbahn änderung von dee dee moore soll
durch die 500 kilogramm schwere
raumsonde tat ausgelöst werden die dem
nasa plan zufolge am 17 oktober 2022 mit
sechs kilometern pro sekunde auf den
asteroiden treffen soll an bord hat sie
ein navigationssystem oder einer
bordkamera damit sie ihr ziel auf jeden
fall nicht verfehlt der aufprall würde
nach den berechnungen der nasa eine
veränderung der bahn geschwindigkeit von
didi moon um etwa 0 4 mm pro sekunde
bewirken
auch wenn das zunächst nach einer
minimalen veränderungen klingt wäre
solch eine neuausrichtung groß genug um
sie mit teleskopen von der erde aus zu
messen
dieses manöver würde zeigen ob wir mit
solch einer mission tatsächlich auch
einen asteroiden der sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befindet
erfolgreich umlenken könnten
denn fest steht schon eine kleine
flugbahn änderung eines asteroiden
könnte das fortbestehen der erde
sicherstellen elf millionen kilometer
wird das asteroiden zwillings system zum
zeitpunkt des aufpralls von dort von der
erde entfernt sein damit die sonde die
übrigens 12 einhalb meter mal 24 meter
groß ist die die man pünktlich erreichen
kann müsste der raketenstart im zeitraum
zwischen dezember 2020 und 2021 gelingen
dazu lindley johnson von der nasa das
wäre die erste mission der nasa welche
die sogenannte kinetic in fekters
technik demonstriert einen asteroiden
mit einem gezielten anschlag von seiner
umlaufbahn zu schieben um sich gegen
einen möglichen zukünftigen
asteroideneinschlag zu verteidigen
eine echte premiere also denn bald geht
es nicht wie beispielsweise bei
bisherigen missionen darum
wissenschaftliche daten zu den
asteroiden zu sammeln wie bei den beiden
als sie ihren besuchen der
nasa-raumsonde osiris rex und der
japanischen mission hayabusa zwei wir
hatten darüber berichtet stattdessen
handelt es sich bei der tat mission sage
und schreibe um die erste planetare
verteidigungsreaktion überhaupt und
werden nicht nur boden teleskope
eingesetzt um den aufprall und dessen
folgen genau zu beobachten auch die
europäische weltraumorganisation esa ist
mit am start auch sie plant eine
raumsonde zu die dumonts zu schicken
hehrer soll allerdings erst 2023 starten
und dort folgen dann könnte sie wichtige
daten zu dem die moz asteroiden sammeln
die esa möchte zudem einen nano
satelliten auf die dämonen aufsetzen
lassen der den von dort erzeugten krater
genau vermessen soll der länder juventas
ist zwölf kilogramm schwer und etwa so
groß wie ein schuhkarton er soll
zusammen mit hera zu dem asteroiden
fliegen und zudem auch mit radarwellen
das innere von dem und analysieren denn
auch die innere struktur und die
oberflächenbeschaffenheit eines
himmelskörpers entscheiden maßgeblich
darüber wie sich dieser beim aufprall
eines objektes verhält genau deswegen
sind auch diese erkenntnis enorm wichtig
um die neue technologie zur abwehr von
us open zu perfektioniert
wir haben praktisch zum science fiction
ja schon über verschiedene techniken
zuerst soliden abwehr berichtet
maßgeblich an der entwicklung beteiligt
ist die nasa behörde namens planetary
die fans koordination office.de erst
2016 gegründet wurde
noch im sommer 2018 hatte die nasa ein
ausführliches strategiepapier zur
asteroiden abwehr vorgelegt demnach
müssen drehen möglichkeiten entwickelt
werden mit denen die flugbahn von
gesteinsbrocken beeinflusst werden
können auch hier betont die nasa noch
einmal dass die wahrscheinlichkeit für
einen einschlag zwar gering ist doch die
folgen umso katastrophaler bis 2020
sollen alle erdmann hast du ihnen die
größer sind als 140 meter zuverlässig
entdeckt werden experten und experten
plädieren immer wieder für eine bessere
weltweite zusammenarbeit und den aufbau
eines koordinierten frühwarnsystems denn
wir alle wissen was bei einem
asteroideneinschlag auf der erde
passieren könnte hollywood filme und
serien dazu gibt es genug fliegende
trümmer tsunami wellen und schlimme
erdbeben etwa könnten einen großteil des
lebens auf der erde auslöschen
asteroiden einfach erklärt klickt auf
dieses video schaut es an und abonniert
den kanal raumzeit block der zukunft es
lohnt sich bis dann bleibt dran